foreign
hey what's up Nelson
hi good morning good afternoon good
afternoon yeah we can hear you what's up
man
okay here's the situation
got an opportunity to refine uh I don't
know if you want me to mention the
company now this can I show up where you
fly they say they would uh pay off all
my credit card debt which is around 45
50 000 that pay off my truck so I'm
gonna pay off my second mortgage and all
what I was a mortgage the interest rate
would go up to 6.7 pounds from four uh
the uh I'll say the payment Nelson
Nelson Nelson yes sir
terrible terrible idea someone is using
the skin off of your butt to put money
in their wallet
don't Cash Out recline don't do it don't
do it don't do it you're gonna make a a
list of your debts and smallest to
largest and you're gonna probably have
to go for a walk around the neighborhood
and weep a little bit and then you're
gonna get after it yeah there's not a
shortcut or a hack through it man well
please don't do this I've talked to
several people and they more or less say
what you say I'm getting an increase in
sale we're not salary my income one
increase about 20 000. good it's over a
hundred thousand a year with every
single Mama track veteran some uh job
and uh Social Security and everything
that'll help me out good all right well
we'll be asking this is my company I
hate Nelson talking to the phone please
I'm using a company that's helping me
that gives me legal protection do I have
to worry about legal protection with
these credit card companies just pay
your bills man yeah no you don't no pay
your bills
okay well I really appreciate it if you
if you join the poly don't hang up yet
if you join one of these refi companies
what they tell you is don't pay your
bills anymore
don't pay your bills we'll take care of
it from here you just sent us a big
chunk of money and we'll take care of
all this stuff
um I did that once what a nightmare
I screwed up everything don't do it it's
almost like a rank it's almost like a
bankruptcy don't do it don't do it it's
actually all marketing language you know
I've heard Dave describe it this way
it's like moving your pile of debt from
one part of the yard to the other part
of the yard right it's still debt I want
to just get real practical here for a
second on two things number one you
don't need legal protection from the
credit card company what you need to do
is is get as John said very serious and
say I'm gonna tackle this thing and the
baby steps will help you do it and so
you take the smallest debt of all of the
debts I wrote down you hit 45 to 50K in
credit card debt you have a truck and a
second mortgage what's the what's the
debt on the truck
uh I think it's like 30 something maybe
what what's the truck worth paid off a
second people almost a 2018 Ford F-150
so
it's got about 70 000 miles on it I
didn't ask you that I'm just saying how
much is it worth
oh worth
I mean selling it I don't know I'm
looking for that 50s right now it's
about 45 000 bucks all right so if
John's right and he usually is
I'm selling that truck and I'm gonna go
get myself an older truck you can get a
fine truck for 15 000. boom we just
knocked out thirty thousand dollars in
debt then you call the credit card
companies up and you go hey here's the
deal I am going to pay you back you
don't worry about any harassing phone
calls you start paying it off get really
serious about knocking those credit
cards out and you'll get there don't
look for a hacks when it comes to
nutrition working out your money don't
your relationship don't look for hacks
go right through the middle of it you
can do this